c'est ce message bouleversant que le
docteur Sébastien marin chef d'urgence à
l'hôtel Barry Memorial a publié tôt ce
matin sur Twitter afin que cette mort ne
soit pas vaine j'ai terminé ma nuit sur
un patient qui est décédé devant moi
avec une aorte thoracique qui rompu et
critique moi je n'ai rien pu faire la
veille ce même patient raconte-t-il
aurait attendu durant 16 heures dans un
autre hôpital incapable de voir un
médecin il aurait décidé de rebrousser
chemin je vois des patients
c'est la vie mais lui ne devait pas
décéder le patient agit depuis de 70 ans
était pourtant connu pour son anévrisme
c'est un cas qui était quand même assez
classe encore qui est très dangereux si
ce patient là avait pu être vu dans des
temps raisonnable on dit pas qu'il y
aurait survie mais au moins il y aurait
eu une chance le docteur Gilbert boucher
qui craint que d'autres puis ses copies
en raison de l'état du système de santé
québécois
servir la population il y a des risques
pour la population partout dans la
province les urgences se débordent rien
de rassurant on espère toujours que le
système de triage va faire en sorte
qu'on passera pas à travers des oncle
des pathologies comme ça malheureusement
là encore une fois depuis 5 ou 6 mois il
y a beaucoup de patients qui repartent
sans avoir de médecins mis au fait de
cette affaire le cabinet du ministre de
la Santé Christian zubé dit avoir
demandé sur le champ un état de
situation détaillée des événements à
l'établissement de santé avec les
changements qu'on est en train de faire
on va rendre le réseau beaucoup plus
solide et performant dans les années à
venir assure son cabinet
oui mais ça va être long ça va prendre
des années des années le docteur Gilbert
boucher croient que des actions sont
nécessaires dès maintenant pour
désengorger les urgences il faut trouver
un moyen de sortir les patients qui ont
plus besoin d'urgence de l'urgence sans
quoi une autre mort évitable pourrait
survenir à tout moment ici à Yacine
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]